we're extremely proud of jimmy and and
committed to jimmy moving forward um
he's our guy as i said from the day he
walked into our building he made us
better and we continue to feel that's
the case and and that's the most
exciting thing about him is the
room for growth he's not come close to
hitting the ceiling and i think the room
for growth the more experience he gets
in this system the more experience he
gets playing in general
we think
the arrows up and that's that's a good
thing
that's 49ers gm john lynch on february
or is the case may be february 25
talking about jimmy garoppolo that would
seemingly close the door on any
speculation about the 49ers pursuing
another quarterback but big cat i was
admit to you
that the circumstances have changed
dramatically since february 25 because
here's the chain of events in a loose
maybe not completely accurate way that
the dominoes fell dion sanders was on
the scouting combine coverage
speculating openly and loudly about tom
brady to the 49ers peter king wrote
about it monday football morning in
america sims and i talked about it on
monday i wrote about it after the show
tom curran of nbc sports boston got in
on the act and gave the whole thing some
credence karen gorigen of the boston
herald citing her sources said tom
curran is on to something and so
throughout the course of the week click
click click i know it's been very good
for business but this thing has grown to
the point where two members of the 49ers
have now come out and publicly addressed
it don't let me finish let me finish
your honor okay
council is making faces and noises while
i try to make my argument
number one jeff wilson jr called it
ludicrous number two george kittle your
friend george aka greg kittle said let's
run it back 10 with a picture of jimmy
garoppolo clear message that he is in
team jimmy my point is this
if the 49ers want to put this to rest if
it is all fake news if it is all smoke
with no fire it is very easy to do it
two ways to do it issue a statement
three ways to do it issue a statement
put lynch or kyle shanahan on a radio
station out in san francisco to address
it or start telling your players there's
nothing to it and trust that they will
tell someone in the media who will
report that the players are being told
there's nothing to it they've done
nothing big cat at a certain point
you've got to do something and i'm not
saying cause people say they have no
obligation to you they they don't have
to tell you that's not my point my point
is if you want to kill this there's an
easy way to kill it and they haven't
done it yet
okay
now can we go back to step one
it all started with dion sanders just
saying it on air
is that right yes
it starts i mean it was kind of
speculation like i
love the media this is the point this is
we just feed each other the ecosystem
feeds it to itself
you'd have been a good lawyer because
you're full of crap all right that's not
the point the point is we are where we
are no matter how we got here we are
where we are right now it's a thing
there are poll questions jimmy versus
tommy yesterday phil sims on with chris
sims unbutton saying he'd take tom brady
we've put out the question sims put out
the question tom curran put out the
question matt mayoko of nbc sports bay
area put out the question it's a thing
now when once you have players on the
team responding and reacting to it
that's when the team needs to look at it
and say you know we'd rather not dignify
this stuff but how hard is it to shoot
it down let's shoot it down mike mike
let's just walk this through okay
because now that i understand this
that's what i'm doing this is crazy all
right so let's let's walk through it
from the 49ers perspective the 49ers
have jimmy g if they cut him at what
date he is basically free and clean
clear april 1. okay wouldn't it ready
for this one they trade him wouldn't it
behoove the 49ers that's hey not not not
as impressive as
uh i agree
i agree but wouldn't it behoove the
49ers to at least have this dangling out
there so they could
renegotiate restructure jimmy g's
contract that's what makes the most
sense to me the 49ers are not saying
anything because these types of rumors
are great for them because guess what
jimmy g is the perfect case of a
quarterback that i think is good not
great you can win with jimmy g can you
win a super bowl with jimmy g everything
else has to be perfect around you do you
know what that means you cannot pay
jimmy g in a crazy amount of money so
now the 49ers have just walked their way
into via dion sanders who probably was
told by someone at the 49ers to throw
this out there so the people like you
and peter king will lap it up and write
about it all week now they have a
negotiating tactic that they can then go
back to the table with jimmy g who by
the way has the same agent as tom brady
and say hey listen we hear the same
thing that you're hearing we love you
but yeah tom brady said he'd come play
here so we gotta at least kick the tires
on it unless
you would like to maybe restructure this
so we have a little bit more room so we
can resign a couple people we would we
owe george kittle a lot of
at money time we got a heartbreak coming
up and i need to respond to this
insanity i'm going to respond to this
insanity after the break because this is
insanity and it proves you've been
hanging around me too much because this
sounds like some kind of weird crap i
would cook up and even i haven't cooked
this up but i have a rebuttal to your
position sir
all right here's one of the benefits of
watching the show on tv you get my
rebuttal to big cat big cat if they are
having any type of reservations about
jimmy garoppolo it will cause them to
try to squeeze him and take less under
his contract that proves why they should
go get tom brady if you view jimmy
garoppolo as anything other than the guy
around whom you build you have under
contract at 27.5 million which is
downright affordable now under today's
market because the high end is 35
million per year and climbing if you
would be thinking about trying to
squeeze him to do some sort of a new
deal
you're proving why you're considering
tom brady you should go get tom brady or
some other upgrade you either love the
guy or you don't and if you don't you
don't try to squeeze him to take less
money you go get somebody else don't go
get tom brady yes and it's a good one
yes and it's a good one no it's not
jimmy g is a good quarterback jimmy g is
a perfect example there are a lot of
quarterbacks in the nfl right now that
you can win a super bowl with and i
count jimmy g there but everything has
to be perfect around them if things are
perfect around jimmy g he can be a super
bowl winning quarterback and you get
somebody else do who else mike who else
throw it out there they don't grow on
trees
of course tom brady like dad thanks does
money grow on trees dad ridiculous yeah
this is regular now i know you're
getting old that you would use the
phrase it doesn't grow on trees it
doesn't now i know why you have to use
that hair dye it doesn't grow on trees
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports